I'll wake up between like 3 30 and 7. I
can't remember the last time we set an
alarm just wake up when I wake up you
would wake up naturally at three o'clock
in the morning oh yeah really oh yeah
for sure do you feel tired or you just
smoke it today at like 4 30. it's a
Saturday if Alex is writing his book or
has ideas like it's the idea that wakes
me up so I'll wake up it depends on if
Layla's up or not if Layla's up then
I'll have coffee with her and then I'll
start working and if she's not up and
I'll not have coffee with her I'll just
have coffee alone just straight to my
desk and start working there first half
is is solo work the second half is group
work and that is that has worked
extremely well for me no disruptions
first half of my day is mine second half
is meetings and that's worked yeah